It's great to see you
hugh jackman is wolverine but that's not
all he is
did you imagine or fantasize that
this is where you would end up
i never thought it was really gonna
happen i think that kind of story feels
very like
okay you can't make this one up tell me
about when you get that first call to
play this character wolverine i mean
do you know who he is do you know
anything about the character you're
nothing
i didn't even know a wolverine was a
real thing and i remember going to an
imax watching a documentary on wolves
thinking wolverine was like a wolf
part wolf some of the stuff that i kept
actually
wolves are driven by their sense of
smell which is why they're always
looking down while you see all these
pictures of them and they're always
looking at your camera now but so i used
to think oh like a wolf
i always need to be seeing my eyebrow
the director said you're doing something
with your body what's that and i said
hey that's cool i've been looking at
wolves and he goes
why i said well you know wolverine it's
like there's
something in the mythology and he goes
no
it's a wolverine i said well there's no
such thing and he goes
yeah like go to the zoo like that's how
little i knew
i'm at the national theatre at the time
and my wife is reading the
scene with me right and i remember her
saying wolverine senses danger his
nostrils flare
uh and snickt she goes what
she goes s-n-i-k-t snickt
claws come out of his hands and she
looks and she goes babe
you can't be doing this what what you
got claws coming out of your hand like
all i have is three pages i don't have
the script i'm like
look it's Ian mckellen and patrick stewart
and anna paquin
i'm going to go for it here she goes
well you're on your own babe, so I went i'm
over the audition
it's the only time ever my wife has been
wrong by the way in 25 years of marriage
so now here you are you've got this part
as wolverine and and clearly as
an actor i'm sure you're pulling from
a number of different sources but
what do you pull from yourself what part
of yourself do you feel
is in logan clearly you are not logan
right it is in me actually
on the surface you don't see that at all
but if i look back at
who i am and every time
my back's against the wall i get filled
with rage
so when i'm younger it was a blind rage
i would have a trigger in that way
there is part of me
i know that can lose it i know that
i can feel it i am not the brooding
dark get out of my face i'll do anything
i want i part of me wants to be that i'm
a complete people pleaser compared to
wolverine right
but on some deep level i get it
probably wish i was a little more like
that yeah and that's a good combination
to have
i also always approach wolverine
knowing that i could never know
everything about
the character that that you know i
approached him with the
seriousness and the intellectual
curiosity as if i was playing richard 3rd
i always thought it was very sort of
greek tragedy like classical theater
so he represents in all of us
this fight between chaos and control
yeah
the animal and the human so you played
this character for a really long time
and you walked away sort of on your own
terms you said
enough time to hang up the claws i had
this feeling underneath that
i hadn't achieved all i wanted to do
with the character that i hadn't done
the character justice i felt there was
just more gravitas more complexity and
so
i thought this is it i need to put
all in i need to take out the safety net
of i'll have another go
i'm going to take that out i'm just
going to go for it
i told everybody this is the last one we
didn't know what the story would be
i'm more interested in what it's like
after the fight and him
finding it almost impossible to live
with himself just that feeling
that you've done something that you may
never get over yeah
i'm not 100 percent sure what it is but i just
have this feeling that i'm
a bad egg i'm actually not
a redeemable character i always really
keyed into that that's a very
interesting take i've never quite heard
that that's great
could you show me how to
grunt and yell like wolverine like
properly you up for it
so before i do any wolverine
i do five squat jumps really as high
right sorry and by so you got your
breath going
and then you have to run so you're
running
go running run
come on
come on you're fighting being live
right
and i'm going to start yelling i look
back now and think oh right
yeah it doesn't just happen absolutely
find the thing you love to do yeah
and then and then work your ass off yeah
every story ultimately reaches its end
wolverine's story isn't over not by a
long shot
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new marvel wolverine
video
they just dropped a new marvel phase
four series that they're doing the first
episode just focused on marvel's
wolverine with hugh jackman
there's a bunch of easter eggs there
were also a bunch of crazy
wolverine and x-men stories that just
got published in the last couple of days
about his time as wolverine the history
of wolverine i know you're all wondering
what's going on with wolverine and
mutants during marvel phase 4
so we'll break it all down if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we're doing an amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know where
you want to see wolverine pop up in the
mcu for the first time
remember there's the idea of them
recasting wolverine during marvel phase
5 and him showing up in other people's
movies then you have the idea of
wolverine solo movies but if you didn't
see this earlier marvel posted this
during comic con as part of this big
marvel phase 4 rollout there was
actually some genuine marvel stuff
at comic con this year even though there
was no big hall h panel in marvel
studios didn't drop any of the big movie
trailers
that's going to be happening later this
year but there's a much longer version
of this where he goes into much more of
his own personal history building up to
becoming wolverine and a little bit more
of his time as wolverine
i tried to just include the best stuff
in this but like he says
he wanted his wolverine to be the greek
tragedy version of wolverine the
character that thinks that he's
irredeemable on some fundamental level
in all the quips and attitude the tough
guy persona is just an act to hide that
then you have all his teammates his
friends his x-men his loved ones you
have people like x-23 in the logan movie
that all keep trying to desperately tell
him that he is a redeemable character
and eventually through his actions he
does wind up redeeming himself by the
end
i also love that hilarious story of when
he first became wolverine was cast for
that x-men 2000 film
and had absolutely no idea who the
character was from the comics
and didn't even know that wolverines
were real animals
it just goes to show you how far he's
come i've also done a couple other
wolverine videos this past year
because lately hugh jackman has actually
been doing a bunch of wolverine related
stuff he just did that funny reunion
video with ryan reynolds deadpool and
the rest of the older x-men cast
but during some of those videos i've
talked a little bit about kevin feige's
own connection
to wolverine and the original x-men
films because that's how he got his
start in hollywood
with marvel studios he got to start
producing on the brian singer x-men
movies he was also a producer on the
toby maguire spider-man movies
but recently the other really crazy
story that hollywood reporter just
published that's sort of connected to
this
is this bonkers brian singer story about
the stuff that he used to do
on the original x-men movies and through
it all apparently one of kevin feige's
jobs was to just mitigate brian singer
and try and rein him in
every day to make sure that the movie
filming didn't get off schedule or over
budget
this is all when he was still relatively
low level kevin feige has told stories
about this era there was a certain point
where they actually
flat out banned comic books on the set
of those original x-men movies
because the studio and brian singer were
just deathly afraid that people would
perceive
the comic bookie stuff like the full
comic book costumes and everything as
being too
silly so if you wondered why everything
looks so drab why they wear those black
costumes why there's so many jokes about
yellow spandex during those movies
that's why there was even one point
during the filming of the original x-men
movie because as hugh jackman says he
knew
nothing of the character he still
doesn't know a lot about the comic book
version of wolverine that kevin feige
actually had to smuggle him and some of
the other actors comic books
on set for reference so they just had
something to go off of because not a lot
of the actors were big comic book
readers
so post all the memes about kevin feige
being a ninja on the sets of movies
smuggling comic books around
but i know you have a lot of questions
about what's going on with wolverine
weapon x during marvel phase four
mutants the weapons plus program is the
next big path to the wolverine character
in weapon x and we're going to see a lot of
that happen during falcon and winter
soldier part of the story of that series
is going to be someone mystery person
bringing back the weapons plus program i
think that mystery person is going to wind
up being thunderbolt ross but he'll
bring that program back
from incredible hulk and that'll be the
path to eventually getting to weapon x
and that's where wolverine comes from in
the mcu
kevin feige has even told stories about
the early marvel phase 1 movies how he
tried to work in x-men cameos wolverine
hugh jackman cameos but it just didn't
work out so will it be fun to see how
they fold in some of those new
recasted versions of characters to the
mcu they've been a lot of rumors about
storm in black panther 2 and then
obviously the full-blown
marvel x-men reboot movies won't be
happening until deep in marvel phase 5.
so everyone just post all your theories
in the comments below where do you want
to see
the new version of wolverine show up in
the mcu first
and speaking of sneaky i just did that
deadpool 3 ryan reynolds video he just
posted a new deadpool 3 teaser
you can click here to watch that and you
can click here for that funny video of
the wolverine deadpool x-men reunion
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe I'll see you guys tonight